يمكن ادراك قوه مقاتلين وضباطنا
بحبهم للوطن
وقناعتهم القويه لان الحق معنا
من اجل الحقيقه
هذا في دمه شعبنا والحقيقه
دمرت النازيه
صارت رمزا
لقوته شعبنا
وهذه المدينه
والقرى المحيطه به بنيت من الصفر اذ لم
يبقى هنا اي مبنى سليم ولا شجره
ان تفعني حماه
تدهش حتى الان وتثير المشاعر الاحترام
والامتنان
وواجبنا المعنوي امام جنود المنتصرين ان
نحافظ على ذكرى
على الذكرى وان نسلمها
للاجيال القادمه ولا نسمح لاحد بتحريف
ذكرى الانتصار على النازيه وتحرير العالم
من هذا الشر المطلق للاسف نرى ان
ايديولوجيه النازيه اليوم
عادت لتشكل خطرا مباشرا على امن بلدنا
فنحن مضطرون من جديد ان نجابها
عدوانا الغرب
يهددوننا بدبابات الالمانيه
ذات الصلبان على
اجنابها
ويريدون الان ان يقاتلون في اراضي
اوكرانيا بايدي
خلفاء هتلر من جماعه
اتباعياندا
النخب الغربيه المعاديه لنا ولدينا اصدقاء
كثيرون في كل العالم بما في ذلك في القاره
الامريكيه وفي افريقيا وفي اوروبا ولكن من
يجرون الدول الاوروبيه بما فيها المانيا
الى حرب جديده مع روسيا
ويعلن عن هذا بلا مسؤوليه على انها حقيقه
واقعه من يعولون
الانتصار على روسيا في ساحه المعارف
على الاغلب لا يدركون ان الحرب مع روسيا
ستكون مختلفه
جدا لهم نحن لا نرسل الدباباتنا الى
حدودهم ولكن لدينا ما نرد به
ولن ينتهي الامر باللجوء الى المدرعات يجب
ان ندرك هذا الجميع ومن يهددوننا
ربما لم يفهموا حقيقه واضحه شعبنا كله
كلنا
تشربنا
تقاليد شعبنا جيل المنتصرين الذين
بنوا بلدنا بدمهم
وسلموها لنا
ان الثبات حمايه
عباره عن مثال نحتدي به وجنودنا وضباطنا
يحتزون بهم
طوال الاجيال والقيم والتقاليد هذا ما
يميز روسيا ويجعلنا اقوياء